[موسيقى]
كورتانا السا ريبليكا وغيرها تطبيقات
حديثه بدات تغزو حياتنا يوما بعد يوم منها
ما يقوم بواجباتك الدراسيه ومنها ما يحمل
عنك عبئا مهنيا بل ان بعضها بات يشاركك
تفاصيل حياتك اليوميه هؤلاء المساعدون
الاليون هم ببساطه ابناء تقنيه الذكاء
الاصطناعي التي معها تغير العالم للابد
فكيف حدث ذلك
ظهر الرجل الميكانيكي بالاساطير اليونانيه
والمصريه القديمه قبل ان ينقله
في عام
1943 الى العالم الاكاديمي وينجزان نموذجا
للخلايا العصبيه الاصطناعيه اعتبر هذا
العمل اول ما نسب للذكاء الاصطناعي
مع حلول النصف الثاني من القرن العشرين
ابتكر عالم الرياضيات الانجليزي الم تورنج
اختبارا للتحققي من قدره الاله على اظهار
سلوك ذكي مكافئ للذكاء البشري لكنه لم
يتقدم عمليا حيث افتكرت الحواسيب انذاك
للقدره على تخزين الاوامر واكتفت بتنفيذها
فقط كما كانت كلفه استئجار الحاسوب الواحد
تصل الى 200 الف دولار شهريا
في عام
ابتكر اهلا نيوويل
برنامج لوجيك فيوريست لتقليد مهارات حل
المشكلات عند الانسان وهو البرنامج الذي
نجح في اثبات 38 من اصل اثنتين وخمسين
نظريه في الرياضيات ووجد براهين جديده
وادله لبعض النظريات
فاعتبره الكثيرون اول برنامج ذكاء اصطناعي
وتم تقديمه بمؤتمر ابحاث داركموث الذي
استضافه جون كريزي ومارفن مينسكي في عام
حينها استخدم مصطلح الذكاء الاصطناعي لاول
مره وكان ذلك مقدمه لتحفيز البحث العلمي
في هذا المجال
بين العامين
1957 و
1974 ازدهر الذكاء الاصطناعي بفضل تعزيز
قدرات الحواسيب على تخزين معلومات اكبر
وتضاؤل تكلفه التشغيل كذلك تحسنت
خوارزميات التعلم الالي والمعارف حول
الخوارزميات فظهرت مجموعه من التطبيقات
المحسنه التي مهدت لتطوير مسيره الذكاء
الاصطناعي مثل
كما ظهرت لغات الحاسوب عاليه المستوى مثل
فورتران او ليست او كوبول بالمقابل عرفت
الفتره ما بين العامين
1974 و 1980 باسم شتاء الذكاء الاصطناعي
حيث شهدت انخفاضا في التموين الحكومي لهذا
المجال
باعتبار ان الانفاق فيه غير مجدل لكن
المنافسه مع اليابانيين اعادت الحماسه
لتمويل الانجليز مشروعات التكنولوجيا حيث
استثمر اليابانيون نحو 400 مليون دولار في
هذا المجال بين العامين
1982 و 1990
خلال تلك الفتره انشا ادوارد فايدن بام
نظام
الذي صمم الاستسقاء المعلومات من خبير في
مجال الاستجابه لحاله معينه ثم يخزنها
ليقدمها على شكل مشوره
لمستخدمي كذلك قام جون هوب فيلد
وديفيدرومي الهارد بالترويج لتقنيات
التعلم العميق التي سمحت للحواسيب بالتعلم
باستخدام الخبره
رغم ذلك شهدت الاعوام من
1987 حتى
1993 شتاء جديدا للذكاء الاصطناعي بسبب
توقف تمويل الابحاث العلميه في المجال
وارتفاع تكاليفها
في عام
1997 هزم بطل العالم بالشطرنج جاري
كاسباروف امام تطبيق
الذي خصص للعبه الشطرنج كما تم تطوير
روبوت الذي تمكن من التعرف على المشاعر
وتقليدها ما شكل فرصه لاحياء البحث العلمي
بهذا المجال مع دخول الالفيه الثانيه بدات
الشركات الكبرى مثل جوجل وفيسبوك
باستخدام تطبيقات الذكاء الاصطناعي وباتت
هذه التطبيقات تقوم بالعديد من المهام
الحياتيه اليوميه وقد يكون تطبيق تشات جي
بي تي الذي اطلقته شركه الذكاء الاصطناعي
open اي اي احد اهم التطبيقات التي احدثت
ضجه في الشهور الاخيره مع قدراته المتميزه
في التفاعل الواقعي مع المستخدمين
والمساعده بالكتابه والترجمه والتلخيص
والكثير من المهام الاخرى رغم النجاحات
البشريه التي تم تحقيقها في هذا المجال
الا ان هناك العديد من الاصوات التي تنادي
بوقف التقدم فيه خصوصا مع ارتباطه بمخاوف
من ان تنافس هذه الالات البشر على بعض
الوظائف مستقبلا